last but not least uh
is vaseline
who's in microsoft research and who's
also one of the long-term participants
and an organizer for this workshop
um
you know
you know as i was mentioning the
beginning of this uh workshop
you know mini max optimization is a
classical field that has found many
applications and it keeps on giving and
one of the interesting
applications of it is in the
uh in in causal inference and which of
course also relates to the other program
that is happening
at simon's uh so
uh nathan carlos already
uh introduced
the connection and vasilis you know
tell us more about it take it away
thanks costa yeah so yes so so nathan
gave uh uh uh presented a paper that's
very related what i'm gonna be
presenting today so um
i'll still give an introduction about
this uh this idea of instrumental
variables and why it's important in
causal inference and how then we get the
the adversarial formulation and then
i'll go to the our main results because
i do think that like instrumental
variables is this idea that no matter
how many times you you see it you always
have to think a second time to
understand what's happening so to bring
people uh you know the same level and so
that you understand the remainder of the
results i'm just going to also give you
an intro to
instrumental variables and causal
inference and then
move to the main part of sort of like
the main results of the talk
okay
so
uh
the the premise is trying to do causal
inference from observational data data
where you did not run an nab test but
where you have a lot of unobserved
confounding so let's see one
example of such a setting suppose that
you're at a company like microsoft and
someone tells you i want to understand
what is the relationship between price
and demand so someone gave you
historical data
where this is the the price typically
you use the log of the price and this is
the demand
how much of the product
people bought and these are sort of
different price points that you have and
so maybe in the data we were offering
some discounts so some people
got some some large discounts some
people got some smaller discounts
and based on that variation of the
discount that some people got and some
people didn't get maybe we want to
understand what's the relationship
between uh demand and price and so you
know the you know the easy thing you can
do is try to fit the data and learn that
relationship the moment you do that
you're going to learn this upward
sloping curve which says that as we
increase price demand is also going to
increase
and that's obviously their own claim
because then you know if
if if that's our causal conclusion
then the optimal thing to do is set a
price of infinity and maximize revenue
right
the
the main problem is that when you deal
with such observational data where the
discount was not randomized but was
given because of some reason you have
what is known as an observed confounding
for instance here
uh you know the sales people that were
giving those discounts uh
were
so looking at customers discussing with
customers trying to understand their
intent to buy and most of the times you
give a discount when someone is not
going to buy so as a in order to elicit
you know like uh
purchase right and then those people
ended up not buying either so you know
you give a discount when someone is not
going to buy and they don't buy
but this is what you get afterwards
right so you get that for people that
you gave a discount and they faced a
lower price they didn't buy and people
that you didn't give in discount
they actually bought
so there is this
underlying variable which is intent to
buy that the sales people that decided
this treatment observed but which we did
not observe in the data right
uh and so
you know like uh in order to understand
ideally in order to understand the
effect we would want to
add that variable into our model and fit
the data with that extra variable where
we don't observe it so how can we
extract causality from such data with
unobserved confounding
and the you know unobserved confounding
is a major hurdle of doing causal
inference from observational data in
almost every application that you can
think of like in in healthcare if you
try to understand for instance the
effect of some drug like immunotherapy
from non-trial data of cancer patients
receiving the drug or not
typically you're going to get some
unobserved confounding
skin where for instance immunotherapy
more late stage patients receive
immunotherapy because it's a more recent
drug than standard of care such as
chemotherapy and so if you do not
observe the stage of the disease in your
data and you just look at the
people receiving the drug and response
you're going to conclude that
immunotherapy is a terrible idea but
it's just because it's given to patients
that are more late stage and so have
short-term survival so the stage of the
disease is an unobserved confounder
um
and similarly
in the tech sector um
[Music]
for instance you can get an anecdotal
thing that uh
when you try to estimate the effects of
customer characteristics on engagement
you might find that people who report
more bugs
uh use the product more and so you might
end up saying you know maybe we should
increase the number of bugs so that
people use a product more but it's just
that people that need the product more
and more engaged already are the ones
that are reporting the bugs and so those
are the people that are going to be
using also the product more next year
and this you know product need is
something that we do not observe
so what can we do in such situations one
of the most
empirically used approach
in particular in fields like empirical
economics and social sciences is what is
known as instrumental variables
where an instrument is a random variable
that affects the treatment
but does not affect the outcome other
than through the treatment
so um
for instance in uh in in the discount
example that i presented what could be a
good instrument
um one one example anecdotally also from
from microsoft you can say you know like
uh
actually not not from my so one example
that you can use to understand uh uh the
effect of a discount if you're in a
corporation that uh
like uh where there's a centralized
approver desk where you send these
discounts and they get approved or not
this to which approver you send the
discount is sort of random and so
uh different approvers might be more or
less lenient
as to which discounts they they approve
or not right so
you can use approver leniency which is a
variable
that
is going to determine the price level
it's going to affect the price level
because you're going to get a smaller
discount
if you
go to a
more strict approver uh
than when you go to more lenient
approver so that's going to affect the
the the discount that you get but
because this approver assignment is sort
of random
this approver linear has nothing to do
with how the customer is going to
purchase the product later on and so
there's no other arrow from that
instrument other than through
determining the price
on healthcare people have used uh the
assignment to ambulance companies as an
instrument because when you call a 9-1-1
and you're assigned to some ambulance
company randomly and different ambulance
companies have some biases towards
particular hospitals and so you can use
that as some randomization in the
assignment as to which hospital you're
gonna go to
uh to understand what is the quality of
care at different hospitals
and that's an example that has been used
in an empirical work
or you know an even more
clear example of a like more
straightforward example of instrumental
variable regression is what's known as
a b tests with non-compliance or in a
data sector you might call them
recommendation ap tests where
you want to run a trial but you cannot
enforce the treatment
but you can do something that encourages
uh
taking the treatment like you can
encourage a person uh to become a member
on a platform
and so you can use this encouragement as
as an instrument to analyze the effect
of this downstream action
so let's see how that
plays out in the discount example so how
would the instrumental variable
regression look like so what you're
trying to do
is instead of fitting the raw data
ideally what you want to do is
project the variation of the price on
the instrument and then try to
understand the relationship in this
projected space
so
say these data points over here are the
data points that come from strict
approvers so they tend to be
higher data points because
you know smaller discounts were approved
then instead of you using these row
points you're going to
project to the
to the instrument so you're going to
average those points and look at the
average price and the average demand
you're going to do a similar thing for
the lineage approvers
and then you're going to learn the
correlation between these projected data
points
and that's going to give you this
downward sloping curve which is you can
interpret as the causal effect of price
and demand
by doing this sort of like averaging
among instrument uh values
but sort of removing all of the effect
from this unobserved confounder and only
focusing on the variation in the price
that's driven by the instrument and
because the instruments serve like
exogenous variation you're essentially
regressing on this exogenous variation
of the treatment that's not controlled
by the unobserved confounder and that's
why you get the sort of like the causal
effect
so instruments uh
where the the idea of instruments goes
back to the early to the to the 20s by
philly pride
whose basic observation the way that he
came up with with instruments was the
following uh so let's look at this graph
basically he said because
there is no
uh unobserved confounder in the
relationship between z and y so there is
no common
parent that
that points to these two variables
and which is unobserved
we can actually estimate from the
observational data what is the effect of
the instrument on the outcome
by simply running a regression
of the of the outcome on the instrument
okay
so this is this quantity over here the
outcome of a regression between the
instrument and the outcome
this is the correlation divided by the
variance of the instrument
so that's the the effect of of sort of
like going from z to y
similarly because there's no sort of
like common confounder common parent
between z and t that is unobserved you
can also estimate the effect of the
instrument on the treatment by running
another regression
okay
that's this quantity over here delta
and basically what he she observed was
well the
and this is a bit hard waving the effect
of the of z to y is sort of the product
of the effects of z to t
times the product times the effect of t
to y which is what we want to estimate
so i've calculated the product i've
calculated one term in that product so
the other one must be the you know like
the ratio of the two
so the the quantity that i care about is
just the ratio of the of this first
effect divided by this other effect and
you get this formula over here
okay
and you can also formalize this idea
through the use of structural equations
so
a common formulation of the instrumental
variable assumption is to say that
suppose that we have this
linear specification
where the outcome is some linear
function of the treatment and this
unobserved confounder plus exogenous
noise
and the treatment is another linear
function of the instrument plus some
function of the
unobserved confounder plus exogenous
noise
and the main instrument the main
assumption that allows you to identify
the effect is that the instrument is
independent of this error
that uh
that goes into the first equation which
is both u and epsilon y so the
instrument is independent of these two
variables
and for other normalization let's make
the mean of these two variables be zero
the overall mean
otherwise you need to add a constant
here
which means that if i subtract
from y
that
treatment effect that i care about
what is going to remain is going to be
independent of the instrument
and it's also going to be overall mean
0.
so no matter what value of the
instrument i condition on
this conditional expectation is going to
be equal to zero
what does it mean for you to
be are you subtracting this position why
like why can't you next uh
oh if you have the constant here you can
assume that you're like that's gonna
make a specification theta plus a
constant there plus that and that's
going to be there but still you're going
to be
picking up the curve
um
so then
from this equation we can go to an
unconditional moment restriction by
multiplying
this residual with z
this is still going to be equal to zero
unconditionally by a tower law and so we
can get
what the coefficient theta that we care
about is which is this ratio which is
exactly what uh philip wright concluded
um
and then you can also go to estimation
you know instead of solving this and
this expectation you're gonna solve the
empirical counterpart of that
expectation and that's going to leave
you to this estimate which you know it's
equivalent to what is known uh
in empirical work as the two stage least
squares estimate
and another way to also justify this
estimate is what i saw in the previous
slide which is first project the
treatment on the instrument so run a
regression of the treatment on the
instrument and then run a regression of
the outcome on this projected treatment
on the conditional value of the
treatment condition on the instrument so
this is another way of coming of coming
up with this formula okay
there are many views uh of instruments
and i i always find like viewing
instrumental variables from different
views useful to
because it's a very sort of like um
it's not a very simple straightforward
uh you know like a
reasoning yeah go ahead uh curiously in
the initial instrumentation of philip
right
there was
did he use
the
normalization of the
mean of the
an observed co-founder i'm trying to
understand if the
structural equation are sufficient and
necessary
to get
a similar results
in what sense
i think the completing part is here like
you know the effect of this is the
product of these two effects of these
two average effects so the average
effect is the product which is the power
defect maybe you have like common
factors that she's saying these are
random no no no
these are there are some other other
parts that affect the effect here that
change the effect that create effective
degeneracy and also correlate the effect
here you won't be getting that equation
but this is one way to
formalize it
so what was the key
assumption that allows us that allows us
to identify this effect the key
assumption is this conditional moment
restriction that also nathan started
started with
uh which needs to be satisfied by our
our data
and you know there is this is a special
case of a more general uh
statistical problem of trying to satisfy
some moment condition conditional on a
set of variables right so m is a generic
moment vector w are some random
variables theta is a quantity you wanna
estimate and see some subset of these
random variables
uh and led to the development of uh
a lot of very uh
important work in econometrics
so the main
starting point of our work was trying to
do this but with flexible uh causal
models so why assume that for instance
that the
the demand is linear in the uh in the
price right so why assume that the the
outcome is linear in the in the
treatment especially for instance when
you deal with continuous treatments
right so which is in case of a price
uh and so we're interested in fitting
more flexible causal models potentially
also including other high-dimensional
covariates that might create
heterogeneity in the effect
so we're interested in in such a
situation where the outcome is some
non-linear some flexible function of the
treatment and the covariates plus an
endogenous error and the main
restriction we're going to assume from
our data is that this error is
independent of the instrument and mean
zero
which is going to lead to uh a similar
set of conditional moment restrictions
that our model h has to satisfy
and for simplicity let me drop the x's
in the remainder of the talk you you can
you serve you can add them back in
easily by
viewing tnx as a new treatment and znx
as a new instrument
so this is the main setup we want to
find the model h that satisfies this set
of conditional moment restrictions and
this is what is known in the
econometrics and and causal inference
and statistics literature as the
non-parametric instrumental variable
regression problem
finding solutions to that conditional
moment equation
and it has a long history especially
post 2000 there has been a lot of
progress in this problem
but
uh you know like uh
and this is a nice set of work that if
you're interested in the problem you
should read but what was sort of like a
bit concerning is that most of these
approaches suffer the um
the the curse of dimensionality so there
they use more classical economic
non-parametric statistical techniques
uh
which typically will
uh
will incur an error that grows
exponentially in the dimension of the of
the space of treatments and instruments
and so even with a small number of
variables you're going to get a very
slow convergence rate on your estimation
so that was one uh one motivation to try
to bypass this curse of dimensionality
using more modern uh statistical and
machine learning techniques
the other major hurdle in uh in
nonparametric iv is what's known as the
weak instrument problem uh the fact that
the problem that you're trying to solve
is basically what is known as an uh
linear inverse problem you are uh
you observe so say this is something
that we observe in the data this
conditional expectation
uh this conditional expectation is equal
to
some sort of like convolution of the
model that you're trying to learn
and your goal is to learn this this sort
of like
function that is being convolved right
so you observe the convolution of a
function and you you're trying to
reverse engineer and learn what was the
function that was convolved
and so you can think that you know like
if this convolution smoothens out the
function a lot you will never be able to
recover those jagged points of the
original function and and that's sort of
like what's
implicitly the weak instrument problem
so with the
example of a weakness
so the instrument typically this
terminology is used even if your
function is linear the correlation
between the instrument and the treatment
is very small okay so and because what
you're dividing by in this in the
previous slide over here in the simple
thing what you're dividing by is
essentially the correlation between the
instrument
and the
and the treatment so you're dividing by
that tiny quantity and so if that tiny
quantity for instance is comparable to
the sample size
you get like what's known as the weak
instrument problem and you get that the
limits of that uh estimate is not going
to be normal right because
that thing that you divide by is
comparable to n or grows within
and the point is that when you're
dealing with non-parametric regression
you almost always have a
weak instrument problem because you can
think of it as
trying to estimate
an iv regression with an infinity of
treatments and then infinity of
instruments and say you're in a linear
say even in the linear case you're
trying to solve this linear moment of
equations but it's like an infinity of
moment equations and then infinity of
variables and so that inverse that's
going to be the the analog of the
division is always going to be an
imposed matrix
and so that the fact that this
minimum eigenvalue of that matrix is
comparable to n
leads to this to the fact that uh
non-parametric is always a a nil post
problem
so for the first part i understand that
we need the dimension free statistics
but yeah so the second one we're not
gonna deal with in
that's another so the classical
literature or nonparametric uh
imposed universe problems
typically knows that smooth and occur i
see so and the iv is a case where you
don't even know that okay
i was trying to think the old fashioned
stuff that we know from the school like
inverse fourier and
again
so all of those are relevant if you want
to understand
the importance of the problem right
um
and you need to this is more like a
question about like functional analysis
and when you go from one function space
to another uh
how do you preserve what is the operator
okay so
in this paper we are going to
sort like sidestep this problem and give
a general theory for the curse of
dimensionality uh but then you can
combine it and i'll maybe go into some
examples with existing results for that
that uh
deal with the ill postness to get a rate
for
uh to get like a concrete rate right so
we're gonna uh it's gonna be clear from
the technical part what what i mean by
that okay
and so the way that we're gonna try to
address the cursive dimensionality is uh
be able to
handle this problem with arbitrary
hypothesis spaces so if someone gives me
a hypothesis space over which i i
believe my model lies in i want to
get a rate that depends on the
statistical complexity of that
hypothesis space so not just the fully
non-parametric examples that is typical
in in non-parametric statistics where
you just
assume some smoothness maybe you wanna
uh
assume some more structure the
hypothesis space but then you wanna have
your
results
decay as a function of the statistical
complexity that the hypothesis space
you might also want the high the error
rate to adapt to the to the complexity
of the true model within that space so
if somehow there's like some norm in
that space and the true model has a
small norm
uh then you want your rate to scale with
that small norm of the true model so
it's sort of like adaptive estimation
and this is where we're going to try to
use the machine learning techniques
which help adapt to this uh
unknown complexity of the truth for
instance if you use techniques like
class or random forest you adapt to the
number of relevant variables or nearest
neighbor regression might be adaptive to
the low dimensionality of the covariate
distribution
and so on and so forth
so the question was you know was can we
turn this non-parametric iv estimation
into a machine learning problem and what
do i mean by that i'm gonna you know
look at machine learning from this
narrow a view of lost me of you know
like a loss minimization
uh so you know you're given a loss
function ld which depends on an unknown
distribution of the data and the
hypothesis space h and n samples from
that distribution and your goal is to
minimize uh that loss function that
population loss function that you
that you
don't know only solely through access to
those samples and so your goal is this
access risk to be
to be small
for the hypothesis that your machine
learning algorithm outputs
so how can we turn the non-parametric id
problem into a loss minimization problem
that was our
first uh
you know
question
and that led to a paper we wrote with
greg lewis a few years back
which
gave the an adversarial formulation of
this conditional moment problem
so we can turn it into a loss
minimization problem that's going to be
an adversarial loss and nathan already
presented it but let me
go through the derivation
so we know that
this conditional moment restrictions
need to be satisfied so that means that
any function f that you can choose
if you multiply
this residual with that function of f
that has to be equal to 0 that
expectation
and so
if i produce a candidate model h
then an adversary will come and say you
know does there exist
uh
a moment of this form
that's violated so if i calculate the
maximum violation among
all test functions f is that bigger than
zero right and then
you know the learner is trying to find a
model that the reviewer cannot complain
about so it's trying to minimize over
hypothesis this maximum moment violation
okay and this is implicitly this maximum
is our loss function
pictorially you know what's happening
here is you have the modeler over here
who is say
presenting a candidate
hypothesis then the reviewer says you
know well let's look at the points where
the
approver was strict the residuals over
there if i sum them up they're not mean
zero
the the the average is not zero so go
and correct it and then the the
modeler is gonna slightly change to
correct that violation and
this game goes back and forth until you
find the solution
and so this was inspired exactly by by
the gun trend uh
back in those days uh
but the the main the technical
differences of the type of moments that
we're testing are different so say if
you look at the wasserstein gun the type
of moments will look something like this
where you know you have a test function
you want the moment which is
that corresponds to that test function
which is pass your data through the test
function and calculate this average
should match
the moment if i pass these fake samples
that the generator is creating
so this is a very different style of
moments than the moments that i present
in the previous line it's actually a
much more complicated set of moments
because for instance the the hypothesis
does not end linearly
in this
you know in this uh formulation and the
test function you know is composed with
the hypothesis that we're trying to
learn so it's a much more complicated
moment problem so there is some
uh we're faced with a more benign game i
should say computationally for instance
um
so then the main questions was uh that
you know like if we if we do the
empirical analog of that where we solve
the zero-sum game in in the empirical
counterpart of the zero-sum game where
we replace expectations with empirical
averages
then does our estimate converge to h
naught and with respect to some metric
of convergence
then how do we solve the min max
optimization problem
uh on the samples
these are the two questions
so 50 minutes okay good
so i'm going to give you the main
theorem and
some applications of the main theorem
and if time permits some experimental
results
uh i should say also that you know this
is a
this work is
as part of a rapidly growing uh
literature in other in using machine
learning techniques for solving the
non-parametric iv problem uh and you
know like what i'm focusing is uh is on
this paper that we originally formulated
this adversarial
approach and then more recently after a
few years we managed to prove some
statistics some formal statistical rates
that achieved this adaptivity property
that i was mentioning right so most of
the technical results are going to be
from this paper that we published two
years ago
so first i mentioned like convergence
with respect to some metrics so what is
the metric that we're going to be
measuring convergence with respect to
and this is the point where we sort of
sidestep the ill posens of the problem
okay
so the quality metric that we're going
to use is what we'll call the projected
root mean squared error
where
you first take an expectation of your
errors conditional on the instrument
and then take the square okay and you're
looking at that projected mean square
there where you first project your
errors onto your under the instrument
space and then take the average
of those squared errors
so this is a weaker than the mean square
there are metric which ideally you might
want to use so the average sort of like
prediction like the average uh squared
error
uh
by simple against inequality if you you
can push this in and you get that you
know the mean square there is a larger
quantity than the projected mean written
square there so the fact that this is
small doesn't really mean that the mean
squared error is small
but the relationship between these two
quantities is exactly what is known as
the measure of importance of the problem
right so
how
can you show that the projected root
mean square root is lower bounded by
some fraction of the root mean squared
error
this tau h which is this lower this
fraction is what's known as the
measurable postness and this fraction is
specific to the hypothesis space that
you're using and also relates to
uh the properties of the strength of the
instrument like so how strong is the
instrument or
does it
how smooth is that convolution
so this quantity
has been analyzed for particular
hypothesis spaces in the past
and even in the paper we provide some
new results on this measurable postness
for reproducing healing hilbert spaces
in the past it has also been shown that
for monotone functions in in 1d
it's this is a constant and also has
been analyzed for the cases of
of
growing linear functions
but in some sense we're going to prove a
result for this metric and then you can
use whatever analysis you want for
bounding the measurable postness to get
the result for root mean squared error
sorry for our case what is the how does
it look like for rkhs you're gonna get
uh
you need to look at how the
uh
uh
the you need to look at the eigen
functions of the of the kernel
and you need to understand
how the projection of those agent
functions onto the instrument space
uh how
sort of like smoothened out they are so
this these eigen functions are
essentially orthogonal before you
project them do they maintain
orthogonality after you project them
uh and if they
don't
uh
and you know especially like at what
rate
this is what's gonna govern the
how they're
they're the measurable poses and this
serve like is the strength of the
instrument does the instrument preserve
sort of the orthogonality of all of this
infinite set of eigen functions uh and
that's also going to hold if you have a
very strong instrument and the stronger
the instrument the more correlated it is
with the treatment
the the larger and in the paper we
basically saw that for arcade chesses if
you do an architecture cases
normalization
you're going to get a tau age that
adapts to the
sort of like oracle measurable postness
as if you you knew that rate
and you
optimally clipped the egg in space to
the top say m again functions and you
chose them optimally based on that decay
that you don't know
so that's a result in the paper which i
found interesting
and also
but but you know like you can get
regimes where that decay is so fast that
your rate for root mean squared there is
going to be one over log n n is the
number of samples so very slow
um
while for the projector that i'm
actuator we're going to get ourselves
always of the order of one over root n
or you know whatever you would expect if
you were solving a a
normal regression right non-parametric
regression
so
the behavior of these two quantities can
be very different
sometimes also when this age model that
you're going to learn is used in some
downstream tasks as a nuisance model in
some other estimation tasks then many
times this metric is sufficient to imply
uh
error rates for that downstream
parameter that you care about
so
sometimes you don't even need to argue
about this and use our metric or
guaranteed direction
so that's an important slide and then
given that
this is our main theorem
so first let me say it in english and
then because the actual definition of
the theorem is quite involved and then
i'm going to
unwrap it step by step
so if the set of test functions that
you're testing is rich enough
and importantly if you te if you change
your objective to add what we will call
stabilizers to the test function
and on top of stabilizers also
regularizers
of the complexity of the hypothesis in
the function space
which injects strong convexity to your
overall loss
while maintaining identification of the
causal model
we can achieve fast estimation rates
that adapt to the statistical complexity
of the hypothesis space h and the
complexity of the true model it's not
within age
um
ask it after because this is you know
this is very big every every one of
these things like it can be you can
interpret it in a gas in your way
so let me but if you want to take a
message this is the message if you want
to learn what it is let me go through
that
sorry for that
so if i if the if
what doesn't mean reaching out so we
need the test function space contains
functions that look
that look like this so you take two
hypotheses in your original hypothesis
space
okay you take the difference and project
them through your instrument
so this conditional expectation needs to
lie in the setup in the function space
okay
that's
one condition
uh you know you can also
allow for approximation errors and
there's gonna be like some extra bias
things if this is just is not contained
by this clause
but this is the main uh
the main
theorem statement
and then what was the other thing to add
stabilizers so instead of just
solving this minimax problem we're going
to add
a penalty over here which is minimize
which analyzes the second moment of the
test functions
so if you recall also nathan had some
some regularized some sort of like
stability
addition to his uh to his minimax loss
but was qualitatively very different it
wasn't just the second moment of the
test functions it was the second moment
multiplied by the residuals so which has
a different uh behavior right so you're
not you don't here we don't even add
residuals in this second moment it's
just the second moment of the test
function and the reasoning why we have
this is also very different to the
reasoning why sort of nathan added it in
order to get the
efficient gmm here we're going to add it
to get these
fast estimation rates
so you have this thing this is very
different from uh um
[Music]
from the classical regularization
approaches in in machine learning so
this is not a regularizer because we're
not multiplying it by some quantity that
goes to zero this is really one over
here so it really changes the loss
function even asymptotically and it
changes it in a way that uh you know
input you know
makes the sort of like the loss function
be much more stable
uh the point being that uh
uh
without this thing
if the
h was
uh so what the test function is trying
to do is essentially match the
sign
of this of this error term over here
right and so even if your
h was very close to the truth and so h
minus eight naught was very
was very good was very small
the test function was going to be it's
going to be sort of like alternating by
trying to match the sign of that error
even if that error is tiny and that we
can create instabilities in your loss
function which can lead to slow rates of
convergence well when you add the square
term here you can complete the square
and essentially argue that what the
test function is trying to do is
learn
the conditional expectation of this
conditional on c so the test function is
trying actually to solve the regression
problem that tries to learn what is the
the average bias conditional energy and
so if that bias is small then this test
function is going to be small
so that's the intuition behind the
stabilizers
then of course you you you know we're
gonna add regularizers which are sort of
like for the standard reasoning that we
want to penalize functions with large
statistical complexity within the
function spaces that we
look at
so this is penalizing the statistical
complexity of the function and this
penalizes the statistical complex of the
h function and the norm here is going to
be dependent on whatever hypothesis
space you're using
then observe that by adding this extra
penalty we don't change what is the
model that's being identified because in
the limit h is the correcting and f is
zero that's the equilibrium and whether
we added an f square doesn't change
so
you know the same
model is going to be the solution to
this and with or without the penalty
the regularizers are going to zero so
that doesn't affect the limit thing that
we convert to right
then if you do that what you're going to
get is a rate that looks like this where
the leading term
depends on what's known as the critical
radius of these function classes that we
use so the function class of the test
function class and the function class
that's related to the h
in fact for you know you can actually
decompose it to er to
statistical complexities of the h
function and the f function but this is
an even tighter
analysis
just need to understand the critical
radius of this function class
and the critical areas is really what i
mean by fast rates
so the criticals radius is a notion of
statistical complexity that's been
introduced in the last
like 10 20 years
in statistical learning theory to be
able to argue tight fast rates in
regression problems in non-parametric
regression problems and so here we
essentially are able to extend the
technology to minimax problems so not
just square loss problems for instance
which is the classical
case where the critical radius has been
used
and if you you know like without this
for example this stabilization argument
we were only able to get rates that look
like the root of that critical radius
which are sort of like the analog slow
rates so think of it for the case of
parametric classes the critical radius
is 1 over 10 so without the
stabilization you would be getting
results of the order of one over into
the one quarters which are not tied for
parametric classes right so when you
have a parametric class you expect one
of the written rates and this is what
allows us to
complete the analysis and do that
and so that's the
you know the main statistical result in
this paper being able to get that rate
and the other main statistical result is
that the leading term is scaled by the
unknown
norm of the true model and this is
enabled by the use of the regularizers
so the regularizers allow you to be
adaptive to this unknown complexity
and this but this is a more standard
trick even for square losses by adding
regularizers you can get such adaptivity
results
you know being able to get the critical
radius was more
non-standard
so that's the main theorem
five minutes
yeah
so uh let me give some example function
classes
uh
and also talk a bit about the
optimization so how do we solve the
optimization problem
or genetically you can do sub grading
descent you know like you say your
hypothesis space was parameterized by
some parameters you take a gradient step
and you know in here
you take a gradient of the
value of the of your function evaluated
at the
optimal test function for the current
estimate of the thetas and the question
is you know how do you solve that
and this is one approach that you can
that you can use for in the following
concrete setting suppose that the
function space that you care about
are
functions that are solely defined via
safe constraints
so we assume that the treatment is
scalar the instrument is scalar the
outcome is scalar and we're trying to
learn
uh
you know like a single dimensional
function
uh from 1d to 1d and we're only imposing
shape restrictions on that function so
for instance you might want to learn a
demand function from a price to demand
and you want to impose that the demand
is monotone which is natural
then
we know how to bound the critical radius
of those functions so that gives you the
critical radius part
and then
you can also solve the optimization
problem
by parameterizing the function
by
the values that it takes on the samples
that you got
and then the interesting thing is that
the inner optimization oracle that you
if you apply is upgrading descent is
equivalent to an
an isotonic regression
in which we for which we have uh
uh computationally efficient methods for
solving it okay
so you can solve them with this minimax
problem for the case of shape
constraints
using some you know gradient descent
versus an isotonic regression oracle
right and that is also efficient so you
get a fully efficient computational
efficient algorithm for solving this
and also prior work and you can also add
other constraints like ellipsis or
smoothness and prior work had also
bounded the
uh the
measure of imposeness by a constant so
for this class of functions you get a
complete theorem even for mean squared
there
i understand that the atomic is to
[Music]
bypass the existence of the
expected value the problem is
concave or not necessary yes in this
parameterization in this case you know
the parameters are what is the value of
the function on the samples so you have
n parameters
so in that end parameters
it's a convex concave right and it's not
like
and also you know you can
you you can solve this
uh for rkhs is you can get a closed
solution using the kernel trick and we
also know what the critical radius is
for many are producing kernel hilbert
spaces and we have an analysis in the
paper for the measurable postness so
there you can also get a complete
theorem
and then goes to more like heuristic
approaches you can use this with neural
networks where we sort of know what the
critical radius is but we don't know how
to solve the min max optimization and
that's sort of like
one of the things we're trying to do
here
and another nice thing that i have for
optimization is that we can also solve
this optimization problem with access to
a
a regression oracle in a classification
oracle
so
uh
the main point is that this l2 penalty
that we added on the test function
actually makes the loss of the test
function player in the output space be
strongly convex and so a very simple
algorithm like follow the leader because
of the strong convexity is a no regret
algorithm okay and then if you write
down follow the letter it basically
becomes another sort of like
regression problem where you're trying
to match these labels and to solve the
square laws so that's one you need a
regression oracle over the test function
space
and then you just best respond
with the modeler at every period and
that is a classification oracle it's
like a weighted classification oracle
that tries to match the labels of the
test function
and with this by running an inaudible
dynamics of best response versus ftl
you can get an ensemble of hypothesis h
which solves the minimax problem and
this is how we get random forest so you
can sort of like best respond with a
with a decision tree and the other
person you know the test function space
solves like a regression with a random
forest and then you ensemble and you get
a regression you get a random forest
that solves the minimax problem
again there are several you know like
you know going from this theorem to
actual random force there are several
open questions that i find very
interesting both on the computational
side on the statistical side but this is
motivates one algorithm that we that we
use that performed very well in
experiments and so i want to leave you
with with that you know like uh there's
some very interesting open questions
with analyzing random forest for this
nonparametric iv and it's actually a
very one of the best performing
algorithms in experiments and
and without the lack of clues
thank you very
[Applause]
much you for the great talk uh any
questions relating list
very nice talk thank you very much
out of curiosity the ftl i
if you can go a little bit to the
equation i was trying uh
like very intuitively you know if it was
a mean and i didn't have the f
of the dice i would say that it is like
a square mean loss but now with the max
how we should interpret it uh
no no
there's a so it's like there's no max
here this is like what the fdl is
solving at every step
so think of the min max game right the
min max game right
one
that's not here okay anyway the value of
the game the you know you look at the
value of the game that's inside the mean
and the max right
the max is oh the max is over the f the
mark is over here right
so one player is trying to
maximize that value
and that's the if you can complete this
question you can get this square loss
fine fine and so ftl is exactly that and
you get strong convexity in the
empirical norm l to norm
and so it becomes you know like a
okay you can prove that you get rates
assuming that the function space is
convex that's an assumption meaning uh a
convex combination of the functions are
in the function space
that's one assumption and do you have
about the imposeness for that case is
there so here no this is just for
solving the optimization problem uh the
random forest and postness you know
that's a different beast i don't think
you can
you know like these are discontinuous
things and so you won't even get any
measure it's only if you think about
them as approximators of smooth
functions
that maybe you get some impulses so you
i think you really need to go to forests
if you just have like a decision tree
with a discontinuity
you're like i see right but yeah so
as a last question for me uh
the imposeness affect also the
consistency of the result at the end of
the day yes if you care so
if you care about consistency with
respect to the mean square there are
metric
yes
yeah yeah it's sort of like a
semi-metric like it might be right so
okay you always get consistency with
respect to the projected metric
but here for random forest even that is
a bit like getting like tight rates even
for the projected metric is uh
interesting
the rates that we're getting here
uh sort of like uh sort of slow rates
you get like the
one quarter of the vc dimension or
something of three
thank you very much yeah
so yeah thank you for the talk um i
guess my question is around the
like relative complexity of the mappings
from z to
x on one hand and from x to y on the
other hand
so what i'm wondering is
let's say
you may have a very non-smooth mapping
because it's fully non-parametric from z
to x and a very smooth mapping from x to
y that seems to mean something about the
classes of functions you use for h
relative to f say or vice versa you
could have a very non-smooth mapping
from x to y but a very smooth mapping
from z to x
i'm wondering like how
uh or where that appears in your
analysis
so the
i think the only place where it appears
is the test functions are projected
through
the z right so the test function space
needs to be h of x conditional on z
right so if that smoothens a lot the
function space then you get a sort of
like you know like a
a much smooth set of test functions
even though your original aids might
have lived in a
more complex set of test functions
is that what you meant
um
i think so i mean somehow like
it's a property of your original data
that like h2 you know x to y is like a
very messy function but maybe z to x is
a very smooth function
so um
i'm just wondering so if z2x is a very
smooth function you might get like uh
impose that will affect the imposeness
right so if z2 x4 instance is a guy is a
gaussian centered gaussian
around the
z that is a very smooth function and
that will give you
tau h will actually blow up so
uh so that might will enter there uh
yeah
so i think yeah the the relation between
gtx enters primarily in the measurable
posiness
quantity
all right if there are no further
questions let's thank osilisa again and
all the speakers of this conference
thank you